we have a dog here right the dog's name
is teacup the dog just came over through
the
window it's the natural state of God
pure empty free already there humans go
through their contraction and then their
expansion and then we quote say that yes
there are certain more purified more
empty more loving ones that kind of
thing okay the future of new Earth is
where those empty loving beings come
together in harmony to actualized the
mission and it is no longer a
centralized like World economic Forum
Shadow hierarchy in government or a
centralized spiritual hierarchy in
government not that there's anything
wrong again with it when it comes to
just the normal way of contraction
seeking expansion nothing wrong with it
there but when expansion at its maximum
comes together there's no hierarchy you
go see a doctor for an ailment like if
you need a a crucial surgery you want a
good surgeon so you go to a good surgeon
or if you want to learn the violin you
go to a really good instructor right to
teach you to teach you the musical
instrument right so in terms of being on
the path towards dissolution of the
separate self then you want those that
are quote most dissolved then when it is
dissolved that's where the equal that's
where the equality that's where the new
Earth Network that's where this type of
thing can happen